a vaccination site in mexico city
an increase in covet 19 cases linked to
the holiday season has also led to a
rise in the number of people seeking the
jab
i feel safe about everything because of
the support that the government is
giving us we believe that everything is
going to be all right because of the
vaccine but mexico isn't the only
country in the region stepping up
vaccination efforts with the omicron
coronavirus variant identified in almost
a dozen latin american countries a new
push for contagion prevention is
underway in brazil which just a year ago
was considered the epicenter of the
pandemic in south america vaccine drives
have become among the most successful in
the world
despite the fact that the president of
the republic is one of the most vocal
leaders against the vaccine in brazil
the brazilian population is already used
to many vaccination campaigns and is
being massively vaccinated
despite a long struggle to launch
national vaccine programs recent data
suggests that south american countries
now have the world's highest vaccination
rates
world health experts have also applauded
the efforts by argentina and mexico to
jointly produce more doses of the
astrazeneca jab seen as a milestone for
vaccine accessibility
while these recent developments are
hopeful health authorities in the region
warn the dangers of contagion are still
high especially as the omicron variant
reaches new corners of the globe
19 epidemic is substantially the same if
a fourth wave will happen because of
omicron what we might see is a high
number of cases but a significantly
lower rate of hospitalizations compared
to what we had in the previous waves
because of the effects of the vaccine
experts from the pan-american health
organization
warned that vaccine inequality continues
to be a major challenge in the region
adding that several latin american
countries are still far from the 50
vaccination threshold necessary to reach
full covet 19 immunity manuel rapalo al
jazeera mexico city